reading some podcasts will you bad
[ __ ] it's July the 10th or the
11th who gives a [ __ ] it's a beautiful
day to be alive the Church of what's
happened now is brought to you by quick
electronic toothbrush let me tell you
something when it comes to electronic
toothbrushes nobody has it down like
quipped why because they have sensitive
sonic vibrations for an effective clean
that's gentle on your sensitive gums
people brush too hard and some electric
toothbrushes are too abrasive 75% of us
use old worn-out bristles that are
ineffective quit is one of the first
electronic toothbrushes that's accepted
by the American Dental Association and
they're backed by over twenty five
thousand dental professionals beat that
and they have thousands of verified
five-star reviews so why do you love
quit let me tell you why it's easy to
carry it's got the timer it's got a
three month battery life that will last
through a season a fun-filled weekend's
away this summer so do me a favor right
clip starts at about twenty five dollars
and if you get go to get quick calm
slash Joey right now you can get your
first rethought pack for free that's
right free
that's your first refill pack for free
and get quick calm slash Joey get quit
GE t qu I p.com slash Joey this is the
electronic toothbrush you've been
waiting for the church is also brought
to you by CBD Lian calm are you by and
CBD all in a liquor store if you die
cancer you deserve when you get your
miserable bastard I'm introducing you to
CBD Lian calm one of the best CBD line
is one of the best CBDs on the market
guess who says it I do because I've
tried them all CBD line makes their
products from start to finish
CBD Lian has you covered whether it's
vape cartridges shadow tincture forget
about it go to CBD Lian calm and check
out their third party lab results
yourself go to CB beetle
I'm calm pressing Church and check out
and get 20% off your order delivered the
house you don't have to go nowhere for
CBD when you got CBD Lyon check this
[ __ ] at me Olli what's going on
my brother man you know just chillin
watching a Lee's fear of bugs all that
bug was I have one buddy just kept
throwing at me he was right because I
don't know if you guys know but this is
700 congratulations
so this is it seems right that you're
eight times you might have survived this
ever I'm definitely nothing that [ __ ]
bug was big huge that [ __ ]
locked them how are you I'm good man
you're looking good I'm trying but I got
a special coming out yeah I still the
smoothness [ __ ]
what's happening man just chillin you
looking good too Lee got some cardio
running from a bug oh it's good to see
him exercise that's enough for a few
months what's going on with the soccer
thing in still going man woman soccer
you all right yeah I'm all then they
finished on Sunday right no I know I
know yeah if they won they just got back
to [ __ ] Jersey and have a parade
tomorrow in New York damn yeah I didn't
even know that part I just watched the
final and then I just left the bar yeah
I didn't know I don't know nothing about
nothing I'm not about one I just know
USA chicks one please the fourth
championship
Eddie felt before second World Cup yeah
second row [ __ ] like that they're only
getting four million men again 100
million they're all upset I got
something to say about that tuna but
well first like yesterday I was at the
bar and I watched the game and after the
game everybody watch the trophy ceremony
but after that everything dissipated and
that let me know we are not in a soccer
country if you are any in any country in
the world that's a soccer country and
you win a World Cup whether men or women
you are celebrating four weeks you know
I'm saying like your hand drums and [ __ ]
outside or komp2 carnival just broke out
people are taking off from work all week
like yeah they won but after they won it
was just over you know saying and that's
not at you in South America you win some
[ __ ] like people are getting pregnant
right now based off that title yes like
in Mexico and the guy scored the goal on
the wrong thing in the the narco shot
him yeah that's a Colombian so yeah a
week later yeah come on yeah weeks later
that you know people are still hurt over
that stuff you don't say like this is
it's more personal and until America
everybody including the players and the
people who love the game get that
personal you know I'm saying we should
kill somebody I'm not saying that until
we win something like get to the point
where it's we're so into it that we you
know when somebody wins an NBA title or
NFL title like that it's a riot was
there any riots yesterday no no
everybody's clapped and walked home when
did your love for soccer come from your
native country growing up I mean where
did your love for soccer come from I was
just born into it like I grew up in I
was born in England right so then you
can't escape it there
it was either soccer or cricket and [ __ ]
cricket [ __ ] with cricket and then so
soccer played as a kid in the schoolyard
like almost every day every day and then
when we moved to Jamaica when I was nine
Jamaica is a former colony of Britain so
one of the few things that they left us
was soccer and I'm saying so moving
there I was another everybody loves
soccer
that's how I used to get girls in high
school you were when you played on a
high school soccer team in Jamaica like
you're in the newspaper you know I mean
it's like college sports here so it's
like you'd want to if you were motivated
you almost a pro you know what I mean
like high school stuff football soccer
is big in Jamaica you know you're you
score a goal your team wins you save a
goal you get a red card you know
anything you're in the paper everybody
all over the island knows about you that
you'll have a nickname and everybody
knows about you so it's just a big deal
does it upset you as a real fan because
every I I don't hate it
but whenever I see the world crowd you
hate it bro I kind of do I like whenever
whenever the World Cup comes around
people pretend like they care like
they're those like those horns a few
years ago
and they really don't like I mean
there's some people who do like soccer
but it seems like a huge majority of
them are just doing it so they can drink
at 6 a.m. and then they don't who really
cares well I never tell how old were you
when you came to the States 17 and what
you is that I never tell because then
people could figure it out yeah the
proximation way year you came to the
States
let's say ladies nowadays you know and
like 73 I got a cat through school
mm-hmm and I was allowed to play
football
mm-hmm but I was too heavy for the
Eagles it was the Eagles and the
Patriots not Bergen in my hometown that
was a high school to high school
Donald all those relationally okay so I
had to play in somebody a Catholic
school in Union City had a what they
called semi-pro but it was there wasn't
a semi-pro it was just a bunch of
[ __ ] kids that couldn't make way on
the regular thing or that bad grade so I
went up there for a couple of games and
I kind of enjoyed it it was a little
rough and I was at my mother's ball one
day and a Spanish dude said did you play
football like oh yeah and he goes do you
want to come play at Hudson County Park
on Saturday was sure hey pick me up my
mother's house you know when I got in
the car nobody had a football shirt on
nobody had a helmet nobody had [ __ ]
shoulder pads and their so when I got
there they were playing soccer
oh and I go what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
and at that time it was in 1975 I mean
Pele was huge right you know that's all
I know about soccer that Pele was huge
but it wasn't what it is today I mean it
took a long time to get to what it is
today
yeah when my first daughter was born in
1990 and and 95 she was playing soccer
and I was like what mmm like I was in
shock then grown to a wreck
yeah sport now I thought it was big in
my area because of the Spanish
population yeah
because of the spent the South American
population the Colombian tissue-like
Ecuadorians el Salvadorans yeah but it
has grown it has made progress what you
have to come with grips --is just
country belongs to the NFL yeah
they even gave it its own [ __ ] day
they took it away from the church what
does that tell you you know what was the
day they took away from the church
Sunday Sunday oh yeah hilarious take
away a Saturday college football said
[ __ ] the ground they took away Saturday
but that's how big football is right and
you have to come to that's why I love
one no good even would say yeah I don't
get footballer Rogan what Dana White
does on a Saturday mm-hm they do 13 of
those on Sunday night twice the size
more tickets shirts follow they got it
yeah because one game holds more than
like yeah like I know UFC a ban you got
to put on multiple fights they do that
every Saturday when the UFC does did
this week they do that every Sunday yeah
for 17 weeks plus the playoffs plus
preseason mm-hm
you know so yeah what are you talking
about the size is it's two different
things we're talking about soccer will
grow in this country but I'll never be
that the elephant no I know like
somebody asked me before I said like
what's wrong with sock and America said
America didn't invent soccer that's the
problem was taught in this country like
every sport you're talking about like
football baseball just whatever other
sports they're thriving in America they
were invented here and you know soccer
is growing here like you said but I've
accepted that it's never gonna be as big
and then Lee was saying do I get mad
when World Cup time comes around people
don't bother back yeah like what every
[ __ ] sport yeah but when the Rams are
playing a bunch of blonde wood Rams
don't even know the [ __ ] RAM is you
know nothing bothers me more than that
say we're talking about conscious shirts
right you have a damn the podcast how
these new kids are just wearing shirts
they go by $40 on t-shirt and take them
aside that means you're bad give me two
[ __ ] songs from that
and I'll suck your dick right now start
stuttering how can you represent but
Joey suppose they don't want a [ __ ]
that's why they stutter I love you but
if I was gonna cause a t-shirt and you
say you offered me a [ __ ] to name to
Sami I'm gonna forget the well it's so
weird how we just don't soccer is
growing and I'll tell you what that same
thing I saw in Hudson County in 1975 or
whatever it was today that same part has
six or seven soccer fields why did they
look like something my buddies the
Assemblyman mmm-hmm so he redid that
part after part they took away the
baseball is he exactly is he worse he
your buddy from Jersey we grew up
together
is he American yes is he Italian what is
it time tell him but he knew that that's
what our town is come on North Bergen a
Charlie's gotta be 60% Hispanic right
you know so what are you gonna do in
fact football is down in this country oh
I believe soccer will grow now mm-hmm
because it's an activity that parents
will put their kids yeah look at the
number of football programs now free
kids under 12 I guarantee it's not what
it was 10 years ago because parents
aren't putting their kids they're
worried about injuries and [ __ ] when
you're my aunt and brain them so I think
soccer will that's another option you
know instead of football so it'll be
soccer now soccer baseball basketball
you know it'll get bigger and I could be
run what you were what you were just
saying about how the NFL does so much
more than the UFC in like Europe doesn't
soccer or football do way more than the
NFL like I don't the save you issues
yeah but but the NFL does great okay
look what happened a couple of weeks ago
oh yeah the Red Sox and like the Yankees
in England right no yeah they're
thinking about moving an NFL team in
England yeah I mean this with TV and the
way everything is like sports can travel
and sometimes it's a novelty to get like
an American game vs everybody
this game is gonna happen one time here
so everybody comes to it and then when I
you know you go to Europe they like I
was in Europe doing shows and I saw
LeBron playing high school his last high
school game was on TV on a cable channel
in England and I was like I mean a high
school [ __ ] kid you know saying like
he was that big so you know sports
travel man and then a lot of soccer
players are friends with a lot of NFL
players and basketball players like they
they talk on Twitter they go visit each
other and they're like cool or like the
big European stars like the name ours
and the messies and the Renaldo's they
know people over here they know you know
the curries and the LeBrons and all that
[ __ ] so it's kind of its kind of really
cool you know saying no it's it's I mean
it's not as big as people would want it
but it's making leaps from yes all right
so the last 30 40 years it's made a lot
of fun leave some mouths did you do
still play soccer all you ever get out
there no I my knees are bad that's it
yeah so how it's just stand up like a
mother he's just standing like a ball
[ __ ] yeah
the last time I got an injury Joey I
didn't even fall I just played that day
and I took me on purpose I just played
lightly and my leg was [ __ ] up for
three months where I couldn't even walk
like when you just get unexplained
injuries like these terrified over here
no yeah I definitely have Munchausen's
look what syndrome do I have you got
every [ __ ] syndrome understand me I'm
less than Jones this is your sixth who
gives a [ __ ] at this point it's hell
that's that's good no you're not I'm
never gonna breathe your fortune let's
give this one away
they just cure itself yeah because I'm
doing the bar oh my god
because you inhale these things see any
queen that you want yes far too
tremendous you look healthy now yeah you
know workout or fart out everything what
uh the special you're excited about it
yeah I'm excited about it what was the
last time you put together a splash a
couple years ago no the CD was with
Coleman then CD we was calling and I
never had a special she was your first
French or a special man one of the best
guys working today one of the best joke
writers in the business and they treat
you like [ __ ] gum with Jones I know
it had to be it's just uh if it wasn't
for like the support or you know I write
on shows and stuff but if their support
of like people like Rogan you like Tosh
and burr you know saying like like
comics that people respect and just
other comics too like hey I'll help you
out more than like the industry
sometimes you know saying which is the
industry's job sometimes you know comics
with power have controlling their own
podcast and [ __ ] they're like [ __ ] it
you should have something or you should
have this and I like the community of
comedy for that you know saying like you
have people on your podcast including me
and you help them out and they come on
and then they get more followers and all
of a sudden that agency wants to help
them more because they see that their
following is growing so I just like that
comics have more control now and more
say you know part of comedy is doing
stand-up and writing jokes and you know
in this life you're not gonna like
everybody know you know life isn't that
fair I wish you could like everybody
mm-hmm but for the most part there's a
handful of comedians and we all get
along and you look out for each other
and you live and die for that
[ __ ]
yeah and that makes that's part of this
job is encouraging especially once you
get past 40 and you've been little and
you're longer in the tooth than the
young guys
sometimes going up to a young pilot
storm comedy three or four years and tap
them on the shoulder saying that's a
funny joke is better than going to
Montreal yeah it's better than getting a
role in the movie yeah it keeps you
going
validation validation from your peers
keeps you going yeah you know I hate
when somebody sends you a tape makes you
validate them like makes you say
something I can't say something I gotta
see you 20 times yeah I gotta see you
with different audiences at the store
how you tackle when you have to follow
[ __ ] and Chris Rock walks it it's over
he was forced to follow [ __ ] Johnny
door with some [ __ ] guy and also to
Chris Rock's Walker and you gotta adjust
your game right and Austin I'm sitting
in the back of my goddamn he and went up
there with no fear
he said [ __ ] Chris Rock he went up there
like [ __ ] a savage you know you
really have to see people damn get along
with people when you see how they asking
after a while you have to reach out you
know just cuz were up there along with a
microphone don't mean with selfish right
does not mean what selfish it means that
we just chose that we want to go up
there naked and if we could join an
improv up and troupe with a guys and
giggle and have your friends come see
and tell you a marvelous you know my
world I respect stand-up comics mm-hm I
really have a big cuz I know what
they're going through
no I know what they're going through at
the fifth year the 10th er 15th year cuz
you've been there yeah I mean you know
what you feel like you feel like [ __ ]
mm-hmm
so when I saw that bill was producing
the podcast for your stuff I was very
happy yeah you know that that that
brings that how many befriended them
[ __ ] I've known it for a long time one
[ __ ] New York you know saying and when
I first moved out here he had moved out
here yet booked some pilot but then I
guess it got cancelled so he was gonna
balance I was like yo stick around was
that that was 97 97 98 or so 88 well
their show got canceled and then he went
back he went back there and he did the
right there and glad he didn't listen to
me he started from scratch
yeah just hitting the clubs
he was a little depressed he llantas
were all depressed when we lose that
shot yeah cuz yeah we think it's gonna
define us because normally because you
seen that be somebody's only shot is
that one shot and if you don't take that
I did some great comics from like the
80s and 90s like you know what's what's
the guy that killed himself in the
shower he's a platypus man he had
nurtured jelly it was one of the
greatest [ __ ] comics we graded this
one shot it felt like and then after
that or maybe had a bunch of pots but
one made it to the air and didn't work
out and that haunted him it feels like
in what's his shot what is the shot I
can describe a shot but people were not
comics people what is a shot well I'll
tell you what a shot used to mean and
then now you don't even know what the
[ __ ] a shot is right now because it
couldn't happen so many different ways a
shot could be today an Instagram post
that goes viral
it could be a YouTube it could be when
you did you just told me off ear you did
the podcast with Rogen in December and
everybody listened to it and then the
guy upstairs that you've been with the
agency for four months called down the
other guys hey you didn't tell me you
had Joey Diaz and then your ball gets
rolling you know what I mean like when I
started a shot was you is a step-by-step
set of shots first you try to get an
audition for Montreal so you get the
audition that's a part of the shot then
you dissin for Montreal and then you
they say yes you can go ma to Montreal
so that's another step or phase of the
shot and then when you're at Montreal
you kill and then then you got meetings
and after the means you get a TV show
deal you and then you see if your show
gets picked up to even get shot that's
another part of the shot and then you
say if the show gets picked up to go on
the air and then you see if it lasts on
the air if it lasts a year or two years
or three years the shot is over you know
I'm saying because nobody will remember
that show is the show that was on
nine to ten years or eight years that
people will remember so but then now you
can kind of fail upwards
I feel like now if you are on a show you
can parlay that now more and say well I
was on this show and people are looking
for people there's more platforms
there's more channels there's more shows
so people are let's get that guy he was
on he was sanctioned by these people on
this network or platform so maybe we can
use him on ours you know what I mean but
it that the terminology shot has kind of
changed
well now shot for me man your big break
right you know many big breaks I thought
I was gonna get thirty thirty you know I
mean let's take the longest shot for
exam I thought that was gonna change my
life right now that way it's been on the
air for thirteen years we get out of the
way right how could it not change your
life look at the cast
look what Adam Sam with damage he was
doing in 2005 no two thousand four two
thousand anything he touched turned to
go well I was shooting the movie they
said it's all wrong it's all right
once this movie comes out you write your
own ticket here's the fucked-up thing I
forgot you think yeah you know it's
that's the fucked-up thing the crazy
thing is that you I remember the movie
getting released and just sitting at
home and looking at the phone and nobody
calls and then dictatorial got a bunch
of movies and Lobo got a bunch of movies
and Tracy Morgan got put and [ __ ] 30
rock and Terry Crews forget what our
Terry grew and didn't forgot he was in
this yeah there I was the [ __ ] ugly
chick at the dance
did you feel bad that when you saw
everybody get me [ __ ] horrible horrible
how would you feel if you thought this
was it your life was going to change
right when I say change what was I so I
think I was gonna be driving a a
convertible [ __ ] Maserati with 20
people in the car no you know what
change was to make 20 weeks at work
200 people coming to my shows maybe
mm-hmm getting the agent to book you
getting a stronger theatrical agent all
right none of that happened
did you have an agent at the time when
you got it yeah he was a bum then and
he's a bum down in Montana Scarface you
know it was it was it didn't change him
that you got that it set me [ __ ] like
the movie came out in May and by October
I was a [ __ ] mess hair son like the
phone and it rang no agents came and
spoke to me you know but if that was
somebody I'm not crying all right that
was somebody else who got it it would
have been all over the would have been a
billboard would have been a variety
plant congratulation to this guy our
client for doing this you know it's just
a weird that things that didn't happen
and I'm not crying I got the experience
of my life yeah but when I was doing
that movie a wise man told me he pulled
me aside one day goes you you're doing
great in this hmm but this is this has
to take time it's gotta take culture
right and recently I seal it you go on
the [ __ ] Rogan podcast mm-hmm
nobody knows who the [ __ ] you are they
look yeah but now they go that's the fat
dude The Longest Yard no I said now they
research more yeah so what I learned was
everything comes back in cultures right
everything that MADtv you did that
nobody [ __ ] saw now one make the air
it 11 o'clock and there's a million
people home because this knows more and
you're a [ __ ] star right so
everything takes cultures everything
comes in cultures mm-hmm what you did in
2007 if it was good history's gonna come
back to repeat itself but you know many
times people call I hit me on Twitter so
I don't know you in my name Israel they
don't know yeah so it comes back now
they'll go pay the flowers right ah now
that's validation ah that's my favorite
show now I gotta go see him all those
things and for me it was not a movie
right like for me it was not a movie
uh-huh it was not me killing on the road
people [ __ ] hated me on the road
and it was telling a hooker story
telling the whole a story about me
mugging a hooker so it blew me away and
you told that on the pocket I told the
little podcast and the only place you
could [ __ ] tell the next thing you
know there was a hundred people at the
show the other day how it would cheering
to tell the hope this story yeah but
like the one thing I have I think you
guys not never missing but maybe don't
realize how big it is because I'm almost
two years in like I see people like a
shot for me is you let me do the Wilbur
is Philippe letting me do a guest spot
at Caroline's like that sort of stuff
that it like to me cuz I got I've seen
people who are a lot of shot no to me
feel like a shot that's just an
opportunity for you to listen to the
ocean from the [ __ ] beach and go oh
that's what the bottom of the ocean oh
but I don't mean I'm gonna get an agent
I just mean like it's it's the next step
if I didn't know right now you got
motion on stage for the next two years
until your tongue you don't think
there's levels of shots no there's
levels of shots but for you or guest by
the caroline's isn't really gonna propel
you it's just to show you what it's
gonna be like it's like when Jim Valvano
may this play is cut the net down mm-hmm
before the season we have to show them
what it was to show them what no I feel
like when they cut the net down right
that's what that's for you for us that's
fuel in your end you got fuel in your
engine right when you go up a further
twelve hundred people and you bomb
you're gonna go home and that's fueling
you and I'll never be mad at here
because we all went through that bomb
the first time we gotta build a big bead
and we throw and they gave you a guest
spot you fought and and you're excited
also they didn't laugh at you now you're
back to square one so it's really not a
shot these are opportunities for you to
peek behind the curtain and go oh that's
what it's like to go up in front of
1,500 people get some experience and
learn do a Friday man that's like you're
at the two-year mark or you need to do
is get on stage but you head down
I don't expect anything but to me that's
a good goal because I see people at open
mic swoop in and open munch for 10 years
and having
a real show because to me that's a shot
me that maybe in ten years some control
in this business you control what you
want to do and it starts by the word no
I'm not doing that normal
I'm not doing that play snowball I'm
gonna lose doing five spots a week but
the two spots that I do do a really
gonna elevate me no those are the things
that at your level right now are you
gotta worry about is what you're not
gonna do anymore and how you're gonna
propel yourself up but I'm the mean one
or you had the look at filbert taught us
a big lesson
Goldberg got his head knocked off with a
TV show that was the reason why it hurt
bill more than it did was because it had
all the makings you know I had to be the
next science though it just wasn't a TV
show with him and [ __ ] some bum from
the store it had the guy from office
space Dharma from Dharma and Greg they
had an all lined up Cassady I don't
remember that show yeah I just remember
he was on it so when he went down if you
learn anything from Tom Rhodes Margaret
Cho greg Giraldo Tom Rhodes Marga Pro
bill burr and greg Giraldo those four
people the biggest lesson I learned was
that once your show gets canceled and
while that shows getting taped keep
getting on that [ __ ] horse
yeah because that's the key what you and
I have witnesses [ __ ] that get
a TV show and go [ __ ] I don't need to
stand up then the show gets cancelled
after three years and then and now those
guys that they were neck-and-neck with
it's doing stand-up I'm now a level on
top of them because they quit and now
their shows a failure and now they gotta
start all over you they're going out
thinking they gotta take a class oh you
want that show that got cancelled and
you gotta start all over again starting
all over again those are the
[ __ ] I take my props often
because most people after this show
fails at CBS they go away they become
real estate agents hilarious they really
do and we've seen it and I've seen it I
can name five guys that came to this
town that had more heat than you me and
Sebastian put together dance
[ __ ] Montreal came down here got a
shutter the TV show to show the power
didn't get picked up now the agents are
a little worried
and then my mistake when might they
happen to walk into the Comedy Store and
they flop the followed I saw a
[ __ ] that was good-looking
looked like Steve Reeves I forget what
his name was looks just like Superman
built like Superman uh-huh went up to
Montreal in 98 got all this [ __ ]
clout deals wasn't funny or just
good-looking he was just good luck yeah
and they gave him there he gave I don't
know if we hate him walking into a store
with four Jews you know a lot of Jews
follow dice the major said he fell apart
ha I never saw him back to town this
door in fact I never saw that
[ __ ] again did nicely with his
Jews only one little assistant you left
for them you know I've seen that a
thousand times I've seen that a thousand
times and people think they come out
here and you know and listen I'm not
gonna lie to you in 1987 I thought if I
got a job bartender like we discovered
just bartending yeah oh yeah mixed
drinks somebody was like comedy call
your perfect Hollywood how is [ __ ]
and I got it and I realize you know
what's the movie that made those two
guys famous not sleepers but the ones
that they went out alright I talked
about swingers swingers there he has a
what are you talking about I gotta work
hard I heard they were giving out
development deals at the airport at LAX
that's what it was like in 95 so her and
the networks found that hard mm-hmm that
the choice is that God all these
networks put on them these guys couldn't
cover the spread
yeah the network's gave money to the
wrong people the wrong people and then
they pulled ours yeah millions broke
millions millions there
I know people got on a list mm-hmm
I heard this from a cab VP Ward's
we're talking he was telling me that Fox
for example mm-hmm every year
they have a list of a 10 to 20 people so
they like past movie stars uh-huh I got
a show on a sale don't give him two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars just
to lock them in just in case something
happens they're playing the long game
yeah just in case somebody picks him up
boom just in case somebody has a script
boom they got it
you know people who are they you
forgotten about all right so I'm like
Geena Davis for example who was hot 20
years ago they get look don't give Jenny
Davis quarter-million dollars and hold
her for a year quite a little millet
some just in case [ __ ] just in case [ __ ]
yeah
then they'll give a couple blacks mm-hmm
deals couple of Tino's deals so when the
[ __ ] black organizations and were
Latino organizations raise their hand
and go what about black people what
about Latino what are you talking about
we gave such and such a development the
do such and such has been on stage for a
year he doesn't even know how to wipe he
doesn't even ought to bring somebody
I still remember that's crazy they just
covering a song I still remember being
at the store the Sunday night and then
bringing a kid in who had destroyed in
Montreal and the kid you could tell by
how he held the microphone that he was a
dud you know how they hold the mic open
by cos hold the microphone when the wind
open you couldn't even do an intro it's
like somebody with their first cigarette
you're not the Comedy Store how you have
to bring up the next guy I didn't even
know how to do the intro when he put the
mic back in he was fumbling they gave
that guy a half a million dollar deal
you're not dumb but after taxes and
everything it's 3:40 right I said guess
what that guy goes and buys a car and
apartment it sure don't get picked up
he's a waiter in six months he's a
waiter in six months it's not even the
shot it's what you do with it mm-hmm
if you're a fighter and I punch you with
the best right hook and you stagger a
little bit and I get on top of you knee
buckles you and gets out I didn't do
that with that right hook yeah you just
need to shot that right what the [ __ ]
you know we got here the shot was this
yeah that was had a TV show
he puts you on reoccurring 6 out of 10
episodes when the season's over I go out
and sell out [ __ ] all the Improv
that's really used to be like no boy you
could do 10 TV shows though ain't no
become the see is what I think Ian's
right if you have you have big Instagram
you can't sell attention to the intro
I'm not talking about that but if you
have an Instagram okay and you hit and
one of these greedy agents these gavones
young and they book you and they charge
$30 for you you're gonna get him for the
thirty one time said go and see screech
he's gonna get you for the thirty one
time and then you're gonna go this is a
waste of my time right
anybody who knows stand up number one
will not fall for that right anybody
who's in the stand-up game all that
fault
yeah the beauty of it now like this
stand-up nerds right they're so invested
they're so much and they follow
everybody if they treat us like Marvel
characters or some [ __ ] or you know DC
versus my back they invest just as much
time into like weirdest person from who
they associated with what they said have
what joke they got like they're into it
and that's beautiful the internet like I
am a new comedy would ever be like that
but it's great that it is because
anybody that spends so much time is
dedicated to calm me when you come to
town they're gonna come and see you
you know I mean so it's sorta and
they're they loyal to you and you're a
part of their lives you know I mean like
like it's not even music you would take
in the place of their music you know I'm
saying like you know you have the
soundtrack to your life I would a laugh
track to their lives and it's just I
don't know when it happened how it
happened but even me I'm taking a while
to realize that myself that oh [ __ ] you
know sometimes people say some [ __ ] to
me I'm like I didn't even remember I
said that or how did you even hear me
say that or hear that comic say that and
people are just invested and that's the
advantage that we have right now I love
what a a stupid [ __ ] show gets hot on
some
the channel and some [ __ ] agent
that's got no morals taste these three
[ __ ] idiots and put some on the road
and that sellout all over the country
these poor guys don't really know it
right they really think they're the [ __ ]
and and laughs you know you you get
people once maybe once twice and then
they go see Ian Edwards for the small 22
right and they go well that was
effective that's a real [ __ ] guy that
knows what he's doing he set up punch
line
he told stories he had structure yeah
continuation you know there's a guy
that's a real [ __ ] stand up you know
then there's not a lot of those guys
around but a real I'm not a real
stand-up I tell stories I use energy to
trick the [ __ ] audience this guy is a
monologist he tricks you with his
[ __ ] words I'm gonna show real
stand-up I'm Eric Greenwood you on the
compliment you gave me and I'm gonna
disagree with you on what you say about
you it's the truth but you have a diff
you just have a you you changed let me
see I put this man you just you're not
traditional but you are definitely a
[ __ ] comic you know I mean I'm
not sit down it breaks my heart that I'm
not tradition really you don't need to
be like it breaks laughs it it's scary
to be you like to go on a part of the so
say the stand-up roses is paved and
everybody goes this way and then Joey's
like out here but he's still getting
there maybe even ahead of the people
that's on there and it's like how to
trust your instinct and do it away
that's never been done you know what I
mean and maybe I don't know
circumstances made you just be like [ __ ]
it I'm gonna be the ultimate Joey the
ultimate me I don't know what it did but
that's that's just dope you know I'm
saying that's what stand up there yeah
it's being the ultimate you yeah we get
here we get tricked Hey the material
about your family you want to share hey
you can't do that mm-hmm hey you can't
do that
then one day something comes out of the
ia [ __ ] itis I wish they all die when
they wanna nice and they get lost and
that's your heart talking yeah that's
what the audience wants yeah and then
you find out how many people who hate
hikers too and then they'll go you don't
work
I'm [ __ ] 8 hi yeah I just want to say
I ain't want to go and I hated everybody
on the path with me it's it's it's your
heart opens up I looked at things I
looked how they wanted to do them and I
refused right that style of I love and
you probably struggled when you tried to
do it
Oh in the beginning the way they said to
do and so you're like I'm in comedy I'm
trying to do the right way they say but
I don't feel like doing it this way but
I have to or else ain't gonna make it
and then the day you're like [ __ ] it if
it means making it yeah I go you're not
going thank him for curing us who raised
you you have no respect I think that one
I think Lee and I and somebody else were
in here the other day and they said I'm
not a good comic when I'm getting ready
for something like I don't ever want to
show yeah I know I don't ever want to
shoot a special again I'm not a special
type of cop I can't shoot special
there's certain time instead of brewing
you and Anthony Jeselnik and there's so
many comics into the setup punchline
they trick it and they take it down a
road they show you their magicians with
their words
they show you this hand they [ __ ]
finger bang you with the other one I
can't I can't I can't do it I get too
tight all right I get to locked in you
know when they say it not performed
before the audience you performing for
the people at home and all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me you know what I want to
see live comedy I want the glass to fall
off the thing and break mm-hmm I think
some of the specials have become too
polished all right and I want to bring
back that nasty gritty you know Richard
Pryor at the improv with their menu by
the type [ __ ] or damn Redd Foxx
recording an album at a [ __ ] party or
some [ __ ] like that how create in the
basement
rosie was that yeah I love all that you
know my web of comedy was putting the
[ __ ] needle on the album and it being
a little bumpy and you just heard a
gritty and you heard people sneezing and
you had people moving this silver way
away from the tables I loved all that
[ __ ] that's all part of the
[ __ ] mystique cuz that type of
[ __ ] takes you right there you're
listening to an album all of a sudden
you're in that room where it was
recorded while you're listening to the
[ __ ] album is like you took LSD and
just transported you to like another
plane you know what I mean sorry I get
that push I feel special for you all
things comedy all things comedy they
have their own crew right there well
they they got a line producer who hired
some people and we like look the
demonstrate but the director is another
comic then his name is a Aristotle
theorists okay and he just did something
on Comedy Central called gold fakes go
face with a bunch of like other Arabic
came for him Oh Jay and Hassan and yeah
I forgot some of the other people's
names right now so he just he directed
that and he acted in that and so he was
good me and him we're gonna shoot the
special regardless we was like listen
man I got to shoot a special by the end
of this year so he said hey man I'll
direct it and so we were out looking for
venues I'm trying to narrow it down and
I was gonna do the concept these friends
are here yeah I was gonna do the concept
yeah it's just hard to bring him in as a
TEDTalk
right regardless and then burn them
hit me up cuz he had a deal with Comedy
Central to produce three specials and he
knew I hadn't had a special meeting but
just done some shows in Atlanta and he
was like hey man you wanna you know
shoot this you wanna be one of the
specials and now I was not I was gonna
use my money they were gonna pay me you
know saying I was gonna try to use my
money shoot it and then try to sell it
but this way hey now I'm getting paid
and there's already a home for it so and
then I get to own it back in like six
years so it's fine I'll take it good day
you happy with it yeah I'm happy with it
you know how did you prepare for it uh
this how prepared for it I knew last
thing that I want to shoot a special so
I turned down writing jobs to prepare
for it like before burn them and hit me
up right I know that if I take some of
the writing jobs I'm gonna be in a room
and I won't be able to hit the club as
much I'll be tired I won't be able to
write hone and you know like prepare the
material like cook it right and travel
so I just turn down any writing job you
know saying and just by the Chosin Vegas
had to chose anyway here [ __ ] party
just anywhere you know it's improv The
Laugh Factory the store in New York just
anyway I just did show did you work on
15 minutes sometimes I would headline
places I'd work out the whole thing I'd
chosen palm there's a way I got to do
the whole thing run the whole thing I
did the rec room and then sometimes 15
minutes I let me work on this part I
have some are come up with a new joke
let me make sure this joke is ready for
the special and it fits in with the rest
of my other material or the section of
material that is going to follow it in
that order so you know just anywhere I
could get on what kind of writing
preparation normally hours a day uh
would you have a time in the mo I always
try to write before I do a set at night
you know so the solution you have to get
your mind go to get my mind on yeah it
doesn't even necessarily have to be
comedy with me all right I can write a
couple paragraphs of the book
yeah that's what I do is to stay loose
just the stainless yeah so I just work
on my [ __ ] before I go on like an hour
or two and then sometimes you come up
with new [ __ ] sometimes you just like my
memories shitty like if I don't go on
for two days I don't even remember the
whole lot and I can't even remember ten
minutes so it's just good to go over and
get a refresher so that I'm not
stumbling crazy up there
you know I mean I felt that I've heard
the delet I didn't prepare correctly for
the left look special mmm why not I
didn't think about it how I should
prepare and if I wasn't know what I was
alone today I would have done five split
to the spots a week at the store at
midnight hmm midnight is perfect know if
I've 15-minute spots Tuesday through
Saturday that's it
hmm nowhere else that's it maybe go to
the improv before the comedy store
mm-hm and trial to set and then polish
it up on the way over to the store if I
ever get a special that of me well I did
my special somewhere in my mind I said
I'm going down to the store love
performer for people who already know
who I am
no I want to try buy material in places
where people don't know the [ __ ] I am
don't put me on the list
so I went to all the smaller clubs
around town mmm and when I got there I
saw myself catering to the room no it's
still of my special mm-hmm and yeah it
didn't hit me so I got in the plane no I
said that next morning went on the plane
back home from Vegas and shoot the
Netflix special was when I hit me I
didn't prepare right that's what I
always say when you get a [ __ ]
to get knocked out mm-hmm well he's
sitting there and the boxes are looking
in his eyes damn really he's fine
all right he's just thinking about all
this [ __ ] how you [ __ ] up all right
you should have worked long as my fans
usually work long as like kicks
you should have tasted a steak to the
gameplay all right I think that working
out at the store
it is like working out at that jibra mom
Holly used to work out well Angelo
Dundee is as good as it gets man you
gotta follow something new every night
it's dark I don't know just something
about working out at the store it's
definitely a Philly boxing gym I bought
the store you know saying our old-school
Philly boxing gym and that's what I like
about it like if your [ __ ] works there
in the oh are most likely to work around
the country unless you go somewhere
where people are just ultra sensitive
you know what I mean and I'm fine with
my material not always working with
those people it wasn't meant for them
it's not meant for everybody everybody's
not meant for everybody so I'm fine with
that but yeah how long he was in the
game for not uh [ __ ] almost 30 years
yeah it's gonna be 20 years for me in
July how [ __ ] crazy is that we stuck
with something for dirty [ __ ] years I
had no choice once I saw Goodfellas what
because I was young when I saw
Goodfellas and it was Joe Pesci and it's
the first time I saw him I said who is
this old [ __ ] and how come he
never gave up and he got this moment and
now his career is gonna last forever I
was like he's acting besides De Niro who
had already had an entire full career
and does Goodfellas and I didn't know
Pesci was in was a Raging Bull raging
law but I don't know how what much time
that was in between Raging Bull and that
but I was like here to quit you know
because back then are you back then I
knew all the actors because they weren't
as many as there are now there weren't
as many channels there weren't as many
studios so you could like so if you see
somebody even if they were had a bit
role you'd notice him so I didn't notice
Joe Pesci from anything so I felt like
this guy kept on acting wherever he was
acting to be ready for this moment I was
like and when I saw that moving at movie
theaters like oh he's gonna win an Oscar
you said that I said that I swear to god
that's how good he was
and when they killed him sorry for any
spoilers when they killed him the movie
was over for me like wow am i watching
this like think about it when when Joe
put Pesci dies and good what else is
left in that movie and I was like this
guy so that that was a weird connection
I made when I saw and I like I'd never
give up and then another thing why I
knew I'd never give up because the
moment I realized I was gonna do it I'm
like I'm doing this for life and another
thing was a I'd quit soccer and that was
my first love and dream and there was no
professional league in this country and
then years after there was one and it
was just too late to get back in a
groove and as I [ __ ] if I'd never given
up I might have been able to play at
least one year in the MLS just one year
or two I was like man I'm never giving
up on anything ever again that I love
and even when I'm not famous or rich I'm
still having some of the most fun of my
life I'm still laughing I'm still
meeting the best people and people who I
end up being [ __ ] great [ __ ]
you know what I mean that you didn't
even know they were just people to you
and you're like you don't know and look
look they end up being trendsetters and
[ __ ] like that and like culture changes
and they're just [ __ ] who are
in the in the in the in the gutter would
you just grind and I was just like this
person from Boston from wherever and
then now we look down the road decades
later and I look at these people and
it's like if I had given up on comedy
that's gotten a job you know how
heartbroken I'd be at home you imagine
right now you know I mean I had the same
experiences you mm-hmm from when I got
left back in the seventh grade my life
became basketball mm-hmm like I was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] man looks like a
[ __ ]
that's all I did I went the Willis Reed
basketball camp you know
superstar with that the Hurley's that's
all I did
I lied took 300 jump shots every morning
like Jerry West that's how I started my
day 300 jump shots you know then I go
play then I go home and lift weights
then I dressed when it was humid then I
go back out and play again and I go home
and eat dinner and then I had late-night
games and I was part of leagues that and
my freshman year some guy just didn't
like me so he didn't start me you know
the fact the [ __ ] that blamed me
and and I was destroyed right I was the
one of the best guys on that team by far
mm-hmm he just didn't like me and I let
that mother [ __ ] beat me yeah he beat
me that I turned to drugs I mean that
was the beginning of my heavier drugs
own like acid his [ __ ] because it didn't
work out I didn't know how to handle and
it's just one guy that was one guy that
endured ten years ago I was going to
kill that mother I heard they just
became a [ __ ] drunk he got fired
uh-huh he was a piece of [ __ ] at the end
and I was like you know a lot of died a
miserable life but he changed my life
forever
all right for 20 years I was pissed off
at him mmm but me quitting basketball
really [ __ ] up me
yeah like it really [ __ ] me like I got
that quick basket boy lasted two more
years in school and because I had no
reason to go to school no more
yeah you know when I first saw him my
name wouldn't define a kid from my
neighborhood made it just - they started
for North Carolina as a freshman white
dude Jersey City six for seven who was
that his name was Michael Coren and when
I heard them go a freshman Jersey in New
Jersey you know like I was just
overwhelmed and let me know I could do
it right it lets you know our
[ __ ] in Jersey City to do it
you get I'm [ __ ] blood Bergen I got
the tool right so when it fell down and
I quit that it bothered me for a long
time and so I knew for a fact mm-hmm
it took me three years to get on stage
from being a [ __ ]
mmm because I knew that once I got on
that stage
there was gonna be no turning back right
my god it was like what do they say when
you get married in sickness or in health
yeah yeah that was it yeah that was it
till death do us part and it was
solidified when I got into the store 97
right I was like now I got a problem
it's like that scene in Bronx Tale
mm-hmm number one he closes the door now
you can't go all right that's what it
was like now I had nowhere to go I was
like which again office of the gentleman
so I buy the followed I'm irreverent
keep taking these beans take me thanks
killing right Tom was killing that
little skinny brother with the dreads
that mean Rogen always talked about the
night news at the store he was spotless
clean he's talking about bouncing a
check and you have a standing ovation
and Les Miz that he had dreads and he
[ __ ] shot a movie that it's books
freely the full effect the Czar's am I
asking gonna help you that came over
here oh you could be on naked and afraid
Oh with this like you know how they get
afraid the bugs eat the people at night
or there's one fart and it's bug free
almost free chef onions and mushrooms I
was eating those onions I was eating
with Lee's name I love these guests fish
or a protein shake today I've got to
shake to Joey's like seven years old
[Laughter]
this is stuck on the Muay Thai shirt no
smell oh when he gets all yeah it's like
go to a Jersey bar when they see all the
smoke cigarettes takes that shirt off in
the morning
like what is that funky [ __ ] odor and
this goddamn shirt but that'sthat's
quitting that devastated him so when I
knew I gotta take up once I got into the
store once ninety-eight came mm-hmm I
was out of all that was 35 or something
and I knew that this was it this is the
only shot I got I've ever do anything
right never mind being successful right
never mind being cabin hard no no no I
was just thinking about just doing just
telling people I got a job not good
enough for me you know though I remember
like in college I went to the college I
went to New York ensue technology
because they have a soccer team that
made it to the semi-finals of division 2
and I was like my sister went there so
imma go there so I went there to see if
I can get on that team you know and I
the first year was terrible because the
fitness level of those guys and they
were English guys Haitians Argentinians
like like people from like that coach
got players from all over the world like
people that didn't make it in the
professionally in England by the time
they were like 19 by then it was over
but they were still [ __ ] good in
top-level shape and there's England had
you know England was into like them not
the skillful player per se but the
robust strong fast robot looking
[ __ ] you know and then these
players were like not as physical as
those British professional players but
they were [ __ ] good and so the first
year was just terrible like we do what
like in a in the morning the drills were
like crazy just a run in cross country
just just fitness fitness fitness so by
the time I got the soccer to do
scrimmage in the evening I got so
fatigued I couldn't even pass the ball
to somebody with my shirt on I just kick
it away it just tired
so then in the second year I was
prepared mentally
pass all the fitness tests I say my ass
off and then the assistant coach is like
you're gonna make the team right and
then he kept on telling the coach wasn't
always down at the field on practice i
Ian's Ian's ready so then that Coach we
had a play a scrimmage game you know
season preseason game against another
team and I was on the bench and then he
put me in and then somebody passed me
the ball and that the defense player got
it from me and then he subbed me right
out and then the next day they had a
team sheet for all the players we're
gonna go on this away trip and I wasn't
on that away trip and I was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] yeah I just quit because I put
so much into it and now I know it's kind
of premature you know so that's why I
call me how old were you back then yeah
like 20 21 what the [ __ ] did you know
then no [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that I don't
yes we think the world is over I thought
it was over
yeah I really really went basketball
ended for me I still played on the
street yard you know I still play in the
school yard but I didn't know what to do
I didn't know what I didn't want to be
one of those guys that transferred
because he didn't play at North Berg and
that [ __ ] goes with their people you
know if you're not playing in the top
that's calling him though no way I'm
[ __ ] there when I was recruited by
st. Anthony's and me this dude why the
old Donald Lear with his big white boy
that was six four five bad [ __ ]
mm-hmm and his first game in the eighth
grade eighth grade sukhothai yeah white
big strong but his first game of the
season that play Kelly school there was
some jumping Puerto Ricans on it and
they broke his [ __ ] ankle Oh
like they say jumped on it and stepped
on and on purpose and leader when went
down so why he ended up me and why they
were freshmen and I just did and I could
see that the kids on the team they were
like in pain like the kids I was tight
with like jacking me braying and whitey
kids I've been playing with for a long
time well I they couldn't figure out why
this guy would [ __ ] him
me man and I couldn't figure it out and
like two years later he got drunk at a
bar one night I told him I hated that
[ __ ] Koko kid there was no way he was
gonna play no he couldn't cut me right
because he was got shot but he knew that
and after that I just hated on you just
he just did not like me and I still
remember being in practices we used to
do this thing Cincinnati mm-hmm where
it's a fast-break drill and brother
I stole the ball if they fast breakdown
me ten times I would steal the ball five
times my god was that good
you know I was a good rebound I was a
great shooter inside the paint I was
tough but he just didn't give me any
love and I just decided the the best
thing to do I quit - thanks bro mm-hmm I
quit them back-to-back
I quit basketball nursed and then I quit
karate and they are so you you have
you're doing karate once I quit
basketball and I started doing the drugs
the karate guys are nice kids
mm-hmm you know so for me to do drugs I
couldn't do drugs around them and when
I'm saying drugs
it was smoking pot drinking windfall but
that's big back then that was big yeah
those karate guys didn't even know like
they look down at that so I was sick and
tired of living that double life so I
just so funny to look back at it
couldn't like I would I would go to
their parties like it's sex and throw a
few sidekicks and we talk about things
then I would go to the [ __ ] drug
parties they get all two to loot stuff
and dated nobody then one day I was like
I can't hang out with them no I'm not
doing the linguist live in one life now
just live like one line imma party i'ma
do my thing and then I quit everything
that set the pace for me means to quit
everything right nothing was good enough
nothing
every time I got a job what am I making
ten an hour I work two days I make what
160
I can make that sound when 8-ball right
once you sell drugs you can't go back to
a day job you know [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
right so I quit everything and it became
I just quit everything
get quit after that I just quit them
when things got rough
quit no quit quit quit and finally one
that go for me to get anywhere mm-hmm
you gotta stick it out yeah you know
it's like when I started selling cause
all the cells go with the hot salesman
Ian leaves then Ian cotton goes bro
you're not gonna believe it
we can't keep the cause he and I go when
they name them going on that 60 days
later I gotta leave when I go somewhere
else the 60 day then I go somewhere else
and then one last stop on my own
dealership mm-hmm none of the twelve
guys I started with that dude that one
dude state huh he's making 200,000 year
because he stayed he learned the product
right and he committed to it me I was
gonna dodge one month let's go sell
Toyota's you don't know nothing about
the car all right you don't build no
rapport and that's why now I learned to
stay with Canyon because I [ __ ] up so
many things that I learned but it's not
quitting the big things as much as the
little things no like every Monday I
have a sheet with the [ __ ] I gotta do I
got for work tops I got two podcasts
yeah I gotta do five and you do a lot of
[ __ ] you end up doing a lot buy-in up
when I might earn on my Instagram in the
morning I see you a morning message
I'm already how is he doing this I'm
already up that's how is it it's like
eight you smoking you saying something
[ __ ] funny and you just start the
morning off right and I won't tweet the
rest of the day just let them know
they're awake mm-hmm they could do it
they could do it right no [ __ ] you
you know when I wake up in the morning
wait damn right don't you wake up and go
damn I had no [ __ ] back into that
office and deal with those people or
whatever and then you gotta kick
yourself in the ass ain't nobody gonna
kick in you gotta go you know what [ __ ]
these [ __ ] man I'm gonna go on in
[ __ ] slap everybody with my dick today
yeah and that's the attitude that gets
you into the shower that's the attitude
that gets you out of the [ __ ] house
mm-hmm
and that's it but I did more I was
taking on the whale we had did more
today the most people do in a week yeah
but even Al's contacting people no one
would think that dude
[ __ ] you know I'm saying like just just
your your just your demeanor your
lifestyle or maybe just your past like
your [ __ ] hard worker bro you don't
seem to be you have to be but you know
what you always hustled what you you
don't work as hard as I do I know for a
fact you do but I might not think I do
weed none of us do yeah because we don't
report somewhere yeah yes we don't
report somewhere yeah but you know I
wake up in the morning at 10 o'clock all
those agents and managers I talk about I
got an email Jack Warner was cracking
today that's the first email I send the
I wake everybody yeah all right and then
after I wake them up I call those
[ __ ]
yeah just let them know the dick is hard
numbers dick into somebody's ass I'm
saying
just send me to that [ __ ] location
I'm gonna drop that [ __ ] bomb on and
it just it it takes a lot to be a
comedian mm-hmm and people really have
no idea and it takes even more now than
it used it before you just wrote your
jokes and if you got a good agent they
would handle everything now you you had
a you got to do everything listen the
agents in the old days had eleven
clients mm-hmm now we change it has 25
clients you know they could do some of
the work for you but they can't do it
all and they won't do it we won't like I
said earlier you have to gather the
sticks and gather the moss rub the
sticks together blow oxygen and
hopefully eventually they'll like the
match all right and set that project on
fire or that thought you have on fire or
that idea you have on fire but you
pretty much got to do the legwork Comedy
Central just didn't give arias
storytellers show no he went into the
[ __ ] little room at the improv will
they serve no booze mm-hmm
then he started selling after bigger
room then he got the digital remember he
got there did you first yeah it was on
Dish Network right the YouTube and then
he got the big show
yeah but he had to start that that
wasn't somebody an agent in calling oh
hey
I just was driving to work storytellers
you're not gonna tell you I got to build
it from scratch
look what killed Tony's doing yeah look
at what the dude did with that you sing
the rocks of road am coming on my man
Josh Josh had a massage out of minds did
a phenomenal job
did the show get picked up a Comedy
Central no but he [ __ ] sold it all
right and if he sold it once that means
you can sell that [ __ ] again and he
still does it
and you know does you know we all forget
was that when I've got into comedy Bill
Maher was on Comedy Central
yeah Bill Maher was one of the original
shows of politically incorrect Comedy
Central canceled him would he take it -
thanks for you know ABC oh yeah and ABC
here with your boy Riley's JP JP
Anderson
what's the KP and JP and this I saw KP
Anacin today look at that that is crazy
in a years or 20 years he's been there
yeah questions when he was a little
writer on we used to go see Bill Maher
uh-huh and he was like a little writer
for Bill Maher my welcome was you know
but I was curious if you had a writing
thing mm-hmm
just to help young comics is there a a
system that you use is there a certain
like like for stand-up it's like let
that marinate a little bit say let it
affect it's gonna think this is going to
be a long answer so you you you'll
probably get hit with a lot more by the
end of this Joey actually blows it over
there that's a little breathing you know
Jesus
a [ __ ] you ain't coughing I'm not
breathing a little half a [ __ ] cause he
had good skin when he first came here
he's not smiling anymore oh good
that is tremendous those are tremendous
four that's Chardonnay right that's how
the little skinny Chinese dude that
leads for the hot dogs that's the kind
of tear gas that coke yeah no he doesn't
even have farts like that I'm sorry so
what was the question again my mind's
just riding you know Scott reset I don't
know one day I was playing tennis with
Mitch Hedberg mm-hmm
don't go Mitch I called you in the
morning I called you in the morning
either dance and he goes I don't pick up
the phone from 9:00 to 11:00 mm-hmm and
he goes that turn everything off and I
just ran I don't get up I take a
breather I [ __ ] around and then I do it
again for another two hours
mm-hmm and I was blown the [ __ ] away
yeah I was really I said on/off for ten
minutes that's why he was Mitch Hedberg
bump was an awful [ __ ] it Ralphie range
right thank Josh wolf Solaris do you
have the same type of me like you said
you just do the the two hours before you
go to the kynect store
like right now I'm naked you know saying
I shot the special in December I gotta
get another 45 minutes at least to start
feeling comfortable again like a hot 45
minutes you know what I mean because you
know people like come seeing it like I
thought they said he was funny they
don't understand you're rebuilding
how crazy you know I mean I hate that
period that's the word I'm will you got
Road dates yeah and you can't keep doing
those jokes and the special yeah and
you're like what the [ __ ] that's why she
was supposed to just take it off all
right just stay at the comedy so you
know jazz alike had some pretty
interesting [ __ ] he says that he he
works out the material for a year and
then he does club for you.they takes
that same material into three theaters
let's go
so take some three
is to put out a [ __ ] special this is
a new our right an S that's respectable
but I've sent people like be selling out
they they skipped the Comedy Store apart
and go straight to selling out weekends
that major comedy clubs like how the
[ __ ] are you doing that how is this
these audience receiving these jokes
like it's just crazy to me the old jokes
or the loser new jokes like they shoot
the special and then you hear are doing
a weekend in Ontario or just wherever
the improv is to support the special now
to write with new [ __ ] well here's the
deal alright so the whole process
changed mm-hmm because again agreed
right yes it all changed because of
greed no okay you had two options just
like a band mm-hmm you either release
the album and tour it mm-hmm and not do
the same material maybe keep the closure
man you know maybe you had a really good
closure on that special mm-hm
and you want to keep that closer to get
the closer as the hottest [ __ ] thing
right you know I see that mm-hmm but so
let's say you shoot the special December
in today's world they're so greedy they
get that [ __ ] out late weeks and
I like that investment has to [ __ ]
flourish for them immediately right so
they get you out right away that's what
I didn't like right now you're stuck
three months first off have to issued a
special you work hard or you have a
heart you want a great week off yeah you
got to take a week off you have an idea
of what you're gonna say next and then
it's like an anything else but three
weeks you struggle mm-hmm you eat bag of
dicks those new joke nothing's working
and the boom you got five minutes
tonight oh [ __ ] I got five money [ __ ]
minutes there's three more weeks and
you're poppin seven and then in that
joke you wrote two years ago that you
had nowhere to put and you find and you
find it boo this now you got 18 cuz I
got a I got a joke like that
there you go my new 25 right now
you go that you wrote four years ago out
about it I was looking through the OPA
Oh
Court the Bible all right boom no yes so
weird how a bit that you wrote six years
ago might not work
that's right now look the old notebooks
I was a great comedy writer joke
comedian told me that he if you look
through your material before you go on
state all these things increase the
percentages of you not mommy
yeah they increase the percentages you
know looking through your material I'm
going scoping through it you know I know
forever you know dice came in here they
goes look at these guys that they
actually think about what they're gonna
cite you know for a young comic I didn't
want them to hear that right I know what
dice means by it
mmm-hmm you know and it's not to get
caught up in your material no to go up
then do you think if the material you
got playing be don't get call about
you're mature it's just you have some
structure but if some [ __ ] happens there
you go you ready but that's a part of
you're ready to to call an audible
immediately if they got three defenders
on you on the right and it did like they
charged in linebackers at you you gotta
be ready for the audible you know I'm
saying you have to be ready Freddie like
I'm yeah and then you know so you know
what you're gonna say but if you don't
get to say it it's no big deal and it's
no big deal it you just have to be
that's comedy you know you have to know
that going in but you have to prepare I
feel like to have the set and but if
some better [ __ ] jumps off from the
audience or there's somebody with a
crazy laugh that night are you saying
earlier if the drink falls you know you
have to react to those things you can't
just be you know and I and I listen to
my I used to record sets and never
listen to him but since I feel naked now
like I just been listening to everything
especially if I don't get to do the hour
before the set you know writing before
the set at least the drive from my spot
to the club I'm listening and then I'll
think of a line that I could add to the
thing and then I've written that day
because
all right and really is is if you add a
line a day and it's 365 days in a year
you got 365 new things and that's more
than an hour you know what I'm saying so
it's like just just stay involved with
your [ __ ]
and even when you're watching your car
you're just doing something in the
shower [ __ ] will come to you because
you're just in tune with it you live in
it you write it right down and you write
it right down you get you get free [ __ ]
you try to write so sometimes something
might come on sometime that but because
you're involved with it and like you or
you [ __ ] around and you just write
anything that has nothing to do stand-up
but when you're onstage [ __ ] comes out
because you you stretched you know I'm
saying you stretch you're ready to to
[ __ ] run the race so then you're up
to speed and you your automatic [ __ ]
kicks in you know saying how much time
difference was it for when you did the
CD for called in to this special say
like three years
I'll show you were way beyond ready yeah
I was ready as is the material was
getting stale yeah I was ready material
was getting sale like that's why I was
like I was gonna pay my own money to
shoot it in December because I couldn't
hold on to that material anymore I
couldn't say it anymore I had to at
least shoot it and put it in a can and
if I didn't sell it at least it was in
the can at some point I could release it
and then I could just move on and go to
the other [ __ ] and start writing new
[ __ ]
whether you should shot it in December
you know it's been seven months yeah six
months seven months here headed by the
Balboa theatre yeah but now where is
that the San Diego I know I remember
reading it's not a shot that was a you
know what that was a you mentioned him
earlier that was Brendan Shaw up he did
the bow board in San Diego I did Long
Beach what's the [ __ ] his name is a
place not forgot how great my memory
that's right he did Long Beach yeah like
December something yeah it is Friday
night mm-hmm Comedy Central yeah eight
o'clock you wear the red night mid
midnight
you ready arrived you embody anything I
didn't put one together but that takes
work Jase were here
you got any dates coming up that these
[ __ ] marvelous people who go support
you see yeah I'll be at the funny bone
in Ohio the week after that was lumbus
Columbus Ohio it was just a great room
great room and then comics in
Connecticut the week after that this is
all in July and then in August I got a
date what the [ __ ] is that date it
doesn't go wait a few hours this coming
out Wednesday yeah
all right go to my website Ian Ayre was
comedian calm
it'll be updated by then and the dates
will be on the calendar
Ian like I told you a couple of minutes
ago I think you're one of the best
comics work thank you brother I think
you're a monologist and a half you
always make me laugh
thanks man the most important you're a
[ __ ] gentleman and you came with any
brussels flavor into this [ __ ]
and a lot of white people I want to
thank you guys for listen do not forget
this weekend I'll be at the Charlotte
calmly zone Wednesday I mean Thursday
Friday and Saturday and August night at
the [ __ ] Lincoln Theater just
one more word from my sponsors and I'll
get out of your hair
let me explain something to you filthy
[ __ ] animals already when it comes to
CBD you're lost everybody's lost nobody
knows what to do with the CBD anymore
you drive around see we do this see we
do that they got y'all confused and have
to [ __ ] you're buying this [ __ ] Oh
God's anyway listen I did the legwork
for you the CBD company you wanna do
business with it's called CBD Lyon calm
they are my favorites I live on the
tinges and the [ __ ] gummy bears
but if you want to smoke it they got
vape they got cartridges they got a
shatter but like I said I'm into the
tension their products are clean and
they aren't like the [ __ ] face that
you with the false advertising that it's
our gas stations they [ __ ] like that if
you're buying CBD or on the gas station
shoot yourself right [ __ ] now
CBD lines may see me deep
Alex from start to finish they have you
covered go to CBB line comm and check
out that third party lab results
yourself what I'm gonna do fee is this
the church family gets 20% off when they
use Church at checkout CH you are CH and
check out that's what type of party it
says so gonna see BB lime right now
right now and pick out whatever you need
I'd go with the raspberry gummies I'd go
with the thousand of 5,000 milligrams
Inc sure to get you [ __ ] going and at
also a if you like the vapors no with
the vapors if you want to do the shad
and go with the [ __ ] shadow go to CBD
lion prescient church on the way out and
get started right now you're gonna be
[ __ ] happy uncle Joey turn John to CBB
line comm slash Church also listen my
teeth the [ __ ] green but it's not
because I don't brush it's because of 30
years of abuse picking your toiletries
somehow always involved a delicate game
of stacking and space acting and you
don't get it started a lotion exploring
all over your Dopp kit that's why I quit
the electric toothbrushes worked just as
well as home or as they do under on the
go I use quip I take it with me on the
road because it's compact and it's wild
and design talks easily in the corner of
your carry-on or your back pocket if you
just spending the night like Oscar
Madison plus the travel ready cover
protects your brush from sandy swimsuits
and luggage slip-ups and there's a three
month battery life that will last
through a season filled with weekend's
away they're making it easier for you to
even keep up with your wake up and wind
down routine when you're out of the
office listen quip is an electronic
toothbrush for an effective clean that's
gentle on your sensitive gums people
brush too hard and some electric
toothbrushes are too abrasive but quip
has a built-in two-minute timer that
pulses every 30 seconds to remind you
when to switch sides and help you clean
your home month mouths evilly up to 90%
of us do not brush for a full two
minutes or don't even clean it
multi-use covers work as a stand and
monster mirrors slides over your
bristles 2pac and Petra protect your
equip on the go brush heads are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars and a friendly
reminder when it's time for a refresh
and to stay committed to your oral
health seventy percent of us use old
worn-out bristles that are ineffective
all right I used to be one of those
people but ever since I've got quit
everything has changed
Clippers one of the first electronic
toothbrushes accepted by the American
Dental Association and they're backed by
over 25 thousand dental professionals
and they have thousands of verified
five-star reviews and kids brush my
daughter brushes with the new brush is
the same as our original virgin just
tweaked for size down mouths kids are
inspired to brush better and more often
with all okay that looks and feels like
the products adults in their life use
and they're proud to use quit my
daughter loves it she just pulls it off
the mirror brushes works at the timer
and she puts her back and she's six
years old and she's got beautiful teeth
that's why you gotta help to develop a
grown-up routine without the childish
gimmicks why I love quick to the reasons
I told you okay it's easy to carry it's
effective and it keeps your mouth clean
you how much bacteria you have in your
mouth quit knocks that out now listen
what I'm gonna do is this crib starts in
just twenty five hours and if you go to
get quick calm slash Joey right now you
can get your first refill pack for free
that's right I said free
listen equip is the future and it's the
way to go the wireless design sucks
easily in the corner you carry on and
you're gonna love it okay do me a favor
gonna quit right now get quick calm
slash Joey and get your first refill
pack for free
that's your first refill pack for free
and get with.com slash Joey I want to
thank CBD Lyon
I want to thank quit but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] for listening support
the podcast I also want to thank en
Edwards for coming out my pleasure home
for being a beautiful guest tonight I'll
see you [ __ ] next Monday tip
top Magoo if not I'll see you Thursday
night at the [ __ ] comedy zone and
bring grief and bring everything edibles
vicodins guerilla biscuits Boogaloo
pills I don't give a [ __ ]
Lee check this goddamn meal